obi-wan kenobi ends with an epic battle
sure to please star wars fans but how
does it set up the events of a new hope
keep watching for the end of the disney
plus series explain obi-wan kenobi part
6 has the daunting dual tasks of
following up the intense part 5 and
setting up the stage for the movie that
started it all to pull this off it
delivers the inevitable climactic battle
early on and devotes plenty of time to
set every piece of the chessboard in the
places they need to be in the beginning
of star wars episode 4 a new hope
hello
instead of a large body count and
constant high octane action obi-wan
kenobi part vi is surprisingly full of
happy endings leia makes her way back
home figures out her fashion sense and
agrees to keep her friendship with
obi-wan a secret the remaining members
of the path evade the imperial forces
riva's arc comes to a surprising
conclusion and even obi-wan's impending
years as a desert hermit turn out to be
considerably more pleasant than you'd
assume let's take a look at the events
of the final episode of obi-wan kenobi
and where it leaves the main characters
considering the difficult relationship
between obi-wan kenobi and darth vader
it's no surprise that a big chunk of the
finale is dedicated to a massive
encounter between the two the former
master and apprentice began an epic
lightsaber battle just 15 minutes into
the episode and it only gets more
awesome from there vader is absurdly
strong force telekinesis is on full
display and while he doesn't explicitly
show it the moment he finally gets a
high ground must be a pretty cathartic
experience obi-wan takes a bit more time
to get his force engine going but when
he does vader finds out the hard way
that he's not the only force user who
can throw massive objects around when
obi-wan finally manages to incapacitate
vader and slice his helmet open the
physical battle turns into a war of
words this may just be the most damaging
part to the duel for both parties as
obi-wan tearfully apologizes for
mustafar while vader denounces his
former identity the jedi gets the
message
goodbye
obi-wan says goodbye to anakin making
clear that he now feels that his former
apprentice no longer exists vader is
left in the desert screaming his
opponent's name in vain hey not everyone
can have a happy ending for fans it's a
thrilling scene it finally shows the
audience a bit of hayden christensen's
vader face and thanks to the broken mask
mix mixes anakin's normal voice and his
booming darth vader voice into a
chilling mishmash or wise the exchange
is also pretty important after all it
explains why a new hope era obi-wan
keeps vader's identity secret from luke
and insists on calling his former
apprentice by his sith name even when
they're alone
for him anakin skywalker truly doesn't
exist anymore
owen and baruch lars have drawn one of
the shortest straws in the entire star
wars live action franchise their death
kicks off luke skywalker's arc in the
original movie and while they appear in
the prequel trilogy their role in the
grand scheme of things is well to be the
humble background from which luke rises
to greatness uru and owen are indeed
fairly ordinary characters especially
compared to the skywalker side of the
family nevertheless the obi-wan kenobi
finale shows that they're hearty and
fearless people who aren't afraid to
raise the son of a notorious force user
as their own they're also cool with
keeping obi-wan kenobi's identity secret
from the imperial forces dangerous as it
may be
that wizard is just a crazy old man oh
and if someone does come calling they
have contingency plans to keep young
luke safe from people who might come for
him this is particularly impressive
because the person who comes in part six
is riva a highly dangerous former
inquisitor luckily for luke owen has
zero chill toward any
lightsaber-wielding authority figure and
neither he nor beru hesitate to face
reba without backup while this
ultimately goes as well as you'd expect
the battle is thrilling and both owen
and beru survive the encounter say what
you want about luke's real father but at
least the obi-wan kenobi finale confirms
that his uncle and ant are on top of
things
as the penultimate episode of obi-wan
kenobi heavily implied the injured riva
has traveled to tatooine to get her
hands on darth vader's son however when
the injured former inquisitor finally
gets looped within lightsaber distance
she realizes that blind revenge may not
be the way to go after all in obi-wan
kenobi part 5 riva is revealed to be a
former jedi youngling who survived
anakin scott walker's attack in revenge
of the sith and she's been seeking
retribution all along however she soon
realizes that killing vader's son to
avenge the youngling slaughter would
make her the very thing she hates the
most when obi-wan catches up the
confrontation between him and the
remorseful riva is a simple discussion
she has realized the error of her ways
and obi-wan offers sage advice like the
jedi master that he is advising who you
become now that is up to you riva may
have seemed like an out-and-out villain
in the beginning but she ultimately
manages to break the cycle of hate and
becomes free from the burden of revenge
since she's one of the few major obi-wan
kenobi characters whose ultimate fates
remain unknown it's entirely possible
that her story isn't over yet since a
grand inquisitor is still alive and the
pair clearly despise each other riva's
potential future appearance might very
well involve another meeting between the
two while darth vader might claim that
anakin skywalker is fully gone the
parallels between him and obi-wan are
still very much present part 5 of the
show is framed as a gigantic battle of
wits between the pair and part 6
continues to measure them against each
other in more ways than one after
obi-wan accepts that vader is beyond
saving and walks away both men
eventually end up on their corresponding
home grounds obi-wan disappears in
tatooine's desert while vader is seen
sulking in his fortress in these
locations both of them meet their
masters vader has a hologram video call
with emperor palpatine who berates his
apprentice by questioning his devotion
and focus vader is left to brood alone
with his ominous theme playing in the
background later we see a much more
pleasant interaction between obi-wan and
qui-gon jinn's horse ghost who declares
that his former apprentice is finally
ready to see him qui-gon also casually
confirms that he intends to hang around
to keep company for obi-wan many fans
have been waiting for beloved jedi
master qui-gon's cameo in obi-wan kenobi
and given vader's huge role in the show
it's not shocking that emperor palpatine
makes an appearance as well however the
way the show juxtaposes the two masters
and their attitudes toward their
students is surprisingly clever right
down to the fact that both characters
appear in incorporeal form no matter how
much power or how many underlains vader
has he's completely alone and palpatine
will call him out whenever he detects
the tiniest bit of weakness meanwhile
obi-wan might live in seclusion but his
former master will always be there for
him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you